hello everybody what is going on welcome
to the third TV with python tutorial
basics video in this video we're going
to be talking about the key D language
so this is where you might see these dot
K V files now it's actually the case
that you don't ever need to use the key
V language it's really there for just
for you if that's what you want to use
but you can actually write the identical
application using pure Python code so as
you can see here we've actually we've
utilized some key language only we've
written it in pure Python but what you
can do is you can use these dot K V
files ah - maybe better organize your
presentation of the GUI and keep the
Python files for the logic so depending
on which way you think you might want to
use our things separately but again it
might actually be the case that your
application or your program is simpler
if you keep it all together in just pure
Python or if you're using a lot of
customization or maybe you're using a
lot of customization but a lot of that
customization is very redundant then it
would make a whole lot of sense to use
the K V files so I think you can get by
using you know doing one or the other it
really doesn't matter but in programming
in general there's a million different
ways to do something and everyone has
their opinion on what the best way is
and they'll ridicule you if you disagree
so I'll go ahead and show both versions
here but honestly don't worry about what
other people say is the best just try
and bolt out see what fits best to you
and use that so anyway that's what we're
going to cover here is the key V
language so first I'm going to do is I'm
just going to go ahead and we'll get rid
of this we're not going to be using it
for now and even we don't need these
imports anymore either so this is kind
of one of our initial scripts only the
only difference here was this was label
and the parameter was text and it said
hello
old worlds like this so save and run
that and that was our original
application if you recall so that's that
and this is you know written in pure
Python now what if we wanted to write
this in or at least utilize the keavy
language so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use notepad plus plus if you
don't have it I highly suggest you get
it you could write all this in just a
regular notepad file and then use the
same saving practices that we're about
to use but anyway so within your key V a
file here what you can do is it's always
a good idea to reference the file that
you are kind of like associated with
because I have seen a second um the way
that the Python script is going to know
the dot K V file to use is really kind
of screwy
I'm not quite sure why they went with
the way that they went but they did so
anyway oh it's supposed to say you know
file name and this is going to be in
conjunction with our a key B video three
for example so key V video three pi put
whatever your file name is you can
require a key V version here by using
the hash tag colon and then we can say
key V one point 8.0 and that will also
put a requirement for the the key B
language file so uh now let's kind of
consult here we've got you know simple
key V app we've got a label and it says
text hello world so you can kind of
envision your K V files now someone's
going to like jump down my throat for
this but dot K V files are a lot like
CSS right so it's a lot like I having a
stylesheet okay and so just like with
HTML and CSS you can kind of write you
know text attributes right in the
paragraph tags let's say for example and
you can give kind of some style
attributes to it or you can have a style
sheet that says hey everything with a
paragraph tag class article right looks
like X right looks like this or you can
actually you don't even need a CSS sheet
you could always just create custom
styles as you went like we can see with
websites it makes a whole lot of sense
to have a style sheet so you don't have
to
continuously keep using classes now with
applications depend on the application
if you have a small application or you
don't have a lot of redundancy it's
sometimes that actually I think is a
little simpler to use it within the
application at least for me but again it
doesn't matter which one you use both of
them are very effective and both of them
will work in the way that you expect
them to so anyways this is a kb file TV
requirement now how would we do this
well like a CSS stylesheet first you're
going to have you know the attribute so
to speak so for us it's going to be we
want to say label now but this is
basically it's a parent okay so this is
referencing any time we use labels so
that's referencing right here but you
could take it a step further and add
other attributes within here we are
going to do that but you could actually
have a button or like other stuff within
here there would be a child all the
labels so every child of a label with X
attribute would be a certain way but
anyway not to get too far ahead of
ourselves I will show that when we get
there but anyway so label 1 2 3 4 just
use the same kind of indentation
practices and then you can have your
actual values here so text we're saying
text colon and then we can say hello
world like this now that's it well it's
all we're going to add right this
instant and what we can do now is we'll
go file save as and I'm going to save
mine um we'll go save file type as and
go to the very top and we'll say all
types so this gets saved here is like
all types like that and then what we're
going to do is we're going to save this
as a simple key v dot K V okay so hit
save and then instead of return label
and then specifying an attribute let's
just say return label so there's nothing
else there so we'll save that and let's
go ahead and run that and see if we work
no we didn't work hold on let's see what
says
apparently simple caveat okay well I
guess I didn't want us to be all cat or
to do camel casing let's go
where here it is okay so it was yelling
at me for the camel casing so I'm gonna
on camel case here so simple kv or
simple ki v under like all under case so
I called it capitalize cap okay for some
reason it didn't like that I don't call
that being an issue before man I still
getting angry at me simple TV I'm
looking at it man I don't know why
you're telling me you can't find it
seems there's a fist ups and takes
lessons TV / simple TV oh it's not dot
oh okay a simple TV now I'm gonna go
back I had used apparently a let's try
this one more time okay save and run
that there we go okay so that's that's
why okay so the the problem was actually
instead of dot K V I hit comma K V
apparently so the camel casing was fun I
just reverted it back to the camel
casing actually so now you can see we
have our application hello world just
the same as it was before it's just now
we're referencing this label now before
we move too much further I do want to
show that
this one yeah there's the comma it's
kind of really hard to see actually it
is a comma I'll just say no there and
let me open this up one last time and
interestingly enough the quv language is
kind of like a I don't know hybrid of
Python almost and so what you can
actually say is text equals hello world
but what if we said text equals for
example hello world and hello plus space
world let's say so we'll save that and
we'll run it and you still see that we
have the exact same hello world but then
what we can do is we can go in further
and we can do hello world and comma 1
plus 1 super get away with that we're an
untested territories at the moment I got
angry okay uh only accepts the string
okay that's fine so anyway we'll come
back over here so that was actually a
parameter issue so let's just do string
1 plus 1 let's see if we get away with
that version at least still angry with
me
source I converted it to a string you
make me very angry um okay well
apparently with our text labels it's
very stringent as far as uh that it just
wants text elements only but when you're
not let's say you're not using the text
element you can actually incorporate
Python logic on the other side of the
colon so at least you can see here with
the plus we've incorporated some Python
logic but again this one's very
stringent in it only wants text but
maybe later I'll show you guys some
actual logic within our keavy language
here but like I said I think the only
reason you would use this dot KB is
strictly to actually separate the logic
and make the keavy file just
presentation
and the Python file just logic but
anyway that's that so if you guys have
any questions or comments please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching things for
all the supported subscriptions
until next time